Suburban women Suburban mothers me
um you know the like where where we're a
class of people who really don't want to
talk about this stuff we don't want to
acknowledge that there's people like the
Canadian professor in in our children's
classrooms and our children's life we
don't even want to acknowledge it
teacher yeah
I mean it's it's something that we just
don't even want to discuss and it's
easier for us just to say well you know
this is it's not this is one crazy
isolated case like people want to live
in denial that is how they want to live
and then you know on on the flip side
when it's like these minor little social
justice issues they feel like they can
just toss out their opinions or you know
it'll it's like an easy one to show how
woke they are in the group of some moms
or something but
um you know I I've reached a point and
partly was because of the last show uh
that I that I did with with you guys
um I'm just I'm just kind of done
staying silent about it and